so Sam this is something that we've exp
I think any streamers experience right
where you want to be like
it's even one of our intros you know you
can't you can't you can't advocate for
genocide on our channel it's it's a
happen so Samurai pumped in like 100
grand for this new project it's a good
amount of money fish tank shows a good
amount of money so here's of course what
always happens with this stuff right
everybody and I and I'm I'm what you're
about to hear I agree with everything
he's saying but but but you tell me what
you think Marsh but basically it goes to
this you do something you want to be
everyone's in free speech absolutist but
then people go oh yeah well I'm gonna
spam the n-word in your chat yeah they
stress test it just to [__] your [__] up
right
you're wrong you're wrong but then then
you get kicked off of YouTube and D live
remember d-lab was monitoring the chat
so anyway here check this out and I
think a lot of [__] creators kind of
feel this way what you guys have created
here is amazing amazing job guys really
loving it will there be any restrictions
filtering the TTS or are you free speech
absolutists now that right there is bait
and we've heard this because yeah
because I I think the best approach is
like the approach we've always said
approach like dick Masterson's always
had where it's like
there is no free speech absolutist they
don't exist anymore on any side so yeah
of course like when people go oh so
you're going to be a free speech asset
absolute what if I dox your kids school
then it's like okay then clearly I'm
gonna have like what the [__] is wrong
you know nobody is a free speech
absolutist and like you said it's bait
nobody really no because it's TTS you
just want to [__] [__] they're
talking about TTS so what they're saying
is is that if he's probably gonna go out
and he's going to want to make something
that just not just spurgs watch also
normal nor some edgier Normie people
could watch and what that means is if
you start doing this project and he's
going to go out there and you have to be
sitting like like we were with Andy
warskin or car while somebody's donating
the n-word over and over and over again
the entire show is just going to become
edgy boy you know [__] and bombs and
[__] like that flying through and it's
like yeah okay it's not that it's not
allowed but it's also
what what is that to add context to this
this this [__] just spent years
trying to [__] heal Old Wounds and
this [__] literally just got the
band back together again and it took
years because Charles was [__] mad he
finally is getting he's they're
literally working on world peace too
while he's doing this fish tank thing
and it's like you guys already want to
[__] burn it to the ground and you
want to just make it off 1488 memes
again and it's like dude I can't blame
him for being like yo can we try this a
little differently man like because
honestly a lot of the [__] Sam Hyde
still gets blamed for he didn't even do
it's all dumb memes
you'll love that watch what do you think
what do you think
we spent a hundred thousand on a project
yes we're free speech absolutists post
pull some lowly
you [__] piece of [__]
stay the [__] away from all my [__]
McLovin and uh Switched at 25 bucks
Chris three favorite metal bands what do
you think about that yeah are you free
speech absolutists no are you [__]
even just let alone the offense that to
me like the idea of you [__] up my
project how stupid how [__] stupid
can you get
yeah and I'm I'm mad for you I'm mad for
you
I'm not mad at you I'm mad like because
I know I know you're [__] your life
up I'm for you Mom an argument should be
made for The Logical distribution of CP
[__] stop you were you're hurting
yourself you're [__] hurting yourself
with all that [__]
uh oh the other thing oh he's not done
if uh people abuse
TTS can go too far uh your account will
be banned and we'll take all your tokens
away so press the gas as hard as you
want
um I'm not even mad at the the person
the thing I'm I'm mad that I've seen
like talented people with come to me
with like Game Dev stuff you've got a
game they made in game maker Studio slit
Graphics good controls it's Sam Hyde
shooting up Hasidic Jews
and they're and like what are you gonna
just what do you want them to do with
that like I get I understand obviously
in a much smaller scale but like I
understand that it's like so what is it
you want like what do you want a spurg
Fest all the time like I'm feeling every
word he's been saying I mean we've been
again like you just said we have been
screaming the same [__] for years with
some of these people that want to make
it oh no let's make a Nazi show and
you're like can you not me can you not
how many people have I yelled at on
Twitter because they meme Us in some
[__] way and I'm like don't [__]
do that or don't you know or have like
our show name in their [__] Twitter
and like no I'm a fan bro and then I'm
like yeah but you're out yeah okay okay
killer 14.88 that's not that's not it
though I wouldn't care if that's your
name I'm talking about when they make
their name like ROTC fan or like merch
fan and then they're out there saying
all this and I'm like they don't reflect
me you know that's why I have a rule
where I automatically ban anyone with
like my name or my show name in their
usernames even if they mean well even if
it's like where's fan I'm like no I
don't want you reflecting me like that
take my name out of your [__]
identity go find an identity so I mean I
feel every word he's [__] saying here
plus he's sweaty which means he probably
just worked out and he's still on
[__] a shitload of testosterone so
he's probably ready to just explode
anyway
you do you uh you know you're 19 years
old
think think about
obviously I flushed away a lot of
opportunities okay
think about when and where is the right
time to flush away the opportunities
all right it's not in the college
admissions essay yep it's not when
you're 21. it's not when you're just
like figuring out where the line is
[__] think and he's right I mean 100
I agree with that you know what I mean
and the difference is and he's also the
point people like us we're going to be
fine because we do our show and you know
we don't have any bosses or anything but
like you some of you guys that do and I
don't I don't want anybody losing their
jobs and [__] like that you know what I
mean I know it's do whatever you want
but and there's just a level of contempt
that comes from being like
you know being misinterpreted and I
think Sam has been struggling for years
with being misinterpreted as the school
shooter 1488 guy [__] Goose stepping
around I hate you you know you do the
you do Jews Rock sketch which is
hilarious it's very funny or you do like
you know like there's been something
you've done some spicy [__] right but it
was always funny right and the problem
is I think a lot of people just latched
on to what they thought was like a
consistent message and it became like oh
okay I'm not focused on the comedy or
all the [__] that you're proud of I'm
just focused on the messaging which was
like yeah [__] Jews right black
people and blah blah and he's like no no
I'm saying like right he was making art
that was funny and at the time when
World Peace was still being made when MD
I think some people forget that we we're
not censored at all
and everyone got a lot like dude there
were people with very hard right views
that were very talented people with hard
left views and they got along with each
other and they collaborated and they
made [__] so mde like World Peace it was
a spicy meatball even for its time but
it wasn't like today where it's like
whoa buddy like you could never make
that now another working on world peace
too and I guarantee you this poor guy is
going to be getting bombarded with
questions from people going is it going
to be like just as [__] edgy are you
gonna do the JQ stuff in World Peace too
if not I'm out it's that kind of [__]
where they want you to be they want you
to start [__] being a champion of
their [__] things and it's like bro
we're just making [__] jokes here
dude grow up
um well and the other thing I just want
to say real quick and he's right is when
he was saying like this whole [__]
like you could tell he's warning this
kid like you're going down that road
where you're gonna be the [__] Lord
contrarian on the internet any like the
fact that he's saying like please get
away from that like I feel for you when
you're the guy that's just to be edgy
going like well what if uh you know is
there a legal uh you know uh argument
for the description you know like it's
that [__] lordy and he's literally
saying don't go down the road don't be
that [__] guy don't live your whole
life like that because it's not a good
there's no good end well so many of
these [__] spark retards don't
realize that like the reason pole
[__] memed him the way they did is
because [__] it was silly to do it it
wasn't because he's super based it was
just about the the shooting one
specifically because that was the Crux
of that was always let's trick this
journalist into jumping the gun and that
was the whole they go no it's just funny
that we say he's the shoe shooter and
it's like you missed the original point
of the joke the original joke was yo if
you contact this this intern at MSNBC
within an hour this [__] idiot is
going to producers gonna tweet out oh
Sam Hyde identified it was funny and
then it became everyone just tweeting
the meme from their [__] account with 13
followers and it's like well that's not
funny that was never funny it was
getting a blue check mark that was like
senior analyst that's CNBC to be such a
[__] Fame hungry piece of [__] that
they would do it so it's like whatever
man